we can't words that quote this vanessa
hudgins real quick people were [ __ ]
pissed at her so this is she says she
goes yeah till July sounds and so
basically the I guess they released some
information saying that this might be a
serious quarantine till about July or
August which is a very long time yeah
she goes um yeah till July sounds like a
bunch of [ __ ] shoutouts to Vanessa
Hudgens ha News were popping wait when
her news came out when she was underage
or of age think she was of age because
music well she was already like 17 or so
I'm sure right okay well if she was of
age poppin if my disgusting she said of
a potential corny to her thirty-eight
point four million followers she was I'm
sorry but like it's a virus I get it
like I respect it but at the same time
I'm like even if everybody gets it like
yeah people are gonna die which is
terrible but like inevitable all the
like all the likes that David said is
actually I wasn't I better have a
hundred forty characters that seems like
a lot more you know and and the funny
thing about this [ __ ] is to is like
number one I I kind of I don't am I
surprised like why the [ __ ] are you guys
surprised yeah some people put these
celebrities on this room I'm not saying
that what she said was smarter or any
saying is dumb as [ __ ] you expect if I
don't I don't expect any better still
people yeah there's still like but the
other thing about this it's just like it
sounds so privileged dude you know
exactly what it is just like man you you
own yet it huh is it Vanessa Hudgens
Mexican some sort of like that why you
[ __ ] talking like a wet up [ __ ] but
if you know who've Inessa Hudgens is
just by the name you've like oh she's
white for sure
truly I guess she put out a public
apology and she was like I'm so sorry
for a lot of people who miss and she's
like I'm very like sorry about seats but
like what she said misinterpreted it's
like is that apology though cuz I can
understand if you didn't understand the
gravity of the situation you know blah I
mean she wasn't [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
insensitive like she don't get a pass
I'm just saying like ice whoa dude why
are you
what's his name he had it to him not
defending Vanessa but I saw her naked so
what's a trade-off home on a teacher's
Alba got it whatever [ __ ] named me
that dude ha hey he had that [ __ ] when
he was on hot ones you saw a little see
all the views with them they're like oh
when he found out he had a corona virus
but it's like dude if Tom if all these
people are all getting it people just
get that [ __ ] but if it's regular people
I mean that's cuz every I honestly
personally think everybody's gonna get
it and the whole thing is like with that
basketball player right now eventually I
he had zeros zeros asymptomatic symptoms
yeah a lot of people apparently yeah and
it's know that this disease came out cuz
now I know what asymptomatic means I
still don't even know what that is like
you guys are kind of explaining well
it's like if you say somebody's asexual
that means that he doesn't have a
preference easy to find women mail
anything attractive again that's what on
me I know a guy that's [ __ ] asexual
is the weirdest [ __ ] oh yeah so like
what does he say when he's asexual
because I've always fascinated by that
ok you know what let me just preface
this with some [ __ ] he never said he was
I know yes because he said it with his
eyes no I've known this guy for many
[ __ ] years right 10 plus years now
and you know we've kicked it we talked
we used to hang out a lot this guy
nothing guys girl so we were watching TV
this is an arcade town my my k-town
apartment off of Wilshire this big old
spot that everybody should come and kick
it at so we were watching some [ __ ]
right and it was a scene where this guy
and this girl was making out this guy's
a grown-ass man two years older than me
he goes I know you was gay gay turn on a
video we were watching some other [ __ ]
right and then it was like these two gay
dudes kissing and he goes what do you
like that you like and now that we have
all this like binary stuff or whatever
I'm trying to figure out like okay maybe
he's like somewhere in between but the
guy is not motivated by any type of sex
whatsoever he is definitely asexual he
must be so productive
he isn't though
straight up I don't know what his
motivation in life is because we've been
all trying to figure out because he's
such a odd but he's hyper talented at
what he does too by the way but one time
we offered him we had to drop off this
package for it was for Comic Con and he
was gonna go there anyways and this is
how weird this guy is I think this is
why I can't figure my he's not motivated
by sex women whatever not even money
because when he was going to comic-con
let's say you're going to comic-con
right you're already gonna go there and
I go hey Nick I'm gonna give you 500
bucks to drop this package off to a
client since you're already gonna go
there just drop it off at their desk
I'll give you 500 bucks what do you say
yeah he said no why we're like why he
goes it's too much work I'm like I want
to what the [ __ ] I just said that I
would give you 500 bucks like the
ultimate hustle right go to a place that
you're already going to and the booth
that he's going to is right there and he
still said no I can't figure this guy
out
either way long story short that full
don't like [ __ ] or I would have made a
post be like hey I'm about to be
delivering packages you would have took
out that 500 and exchanged for just once
[Laughter]
though the craziest thing they'll Trump
the Trump yeah was oh yes I'm at it's
like I know virus or some [ __ ] he said
it's like well we'll all survives a
child bro this guy dude
literally have you seen the video clip
of him talking about he's like people
always ask me how I know so much about
the corona virus like he's talking about
the corona virus and he's literally
bringing himself into it talking about
like how much he knows he's like I
probably should have been a scientist or
something people say I'm a naturalist
because that has it he probably does
have it if it really does if it's this
it's this contagious he was in contact
with the Brazilian from now I mean that
Fool has it he